so black against
il 2000 and I'll take
a look at it in 2014 too D
bit yes well okay let's try
the tataka variant again here I
want
the very old continuation here with the
direct exchange on
d5 a bit out of
fashion bishop die3 yes I think that's
harmless  Well,
at least according to the normal theory,
yes here you can often bring the bishop
to E6 instead of to
B7
aha
h yes, well, knight D7 then he has
knight C6 or yes, I can't get him
out of there that quickly, no, he
might want to play F4  yes
F4 okay, first of all I'll make the
move according to the program, I can't get by without it
anyway,
so I'll do it now,
and
then knight D7 he'll actually do
F4 yes, it's possible, no, it's
possible, yes, good, but what else should I
play except  Knight D7 even if F4
is somehow a good idea here,
I don't have any other move so I
could
maybe take D4 first on F4,
yes he did, so I'll take
D4
out
so maybe F5 is really threatening,
yes that's the position
Definitely better for I don't
know
if I played stupidly,
the problem now is not so much a
king's attack or something, but also here
the
z lines still have bishop A6
and such
moves, yes, so that's a
bit uncomfortable here, that here is B6
if it were on B7
it wouldn't be so
bad,
but it still goes towards the
kingside, I have no idea, I think there
would have been more to gain on the queenside, so
now I can at least swap the rook here
and play rook C8
or
take away rook  which now also exchanges
so no, he doesn't do it okay, but
now I actually thought maybe
Queen B4
or D4 is hanging, B2 is hanging and E1
is hanging, yes, that was to be expected, so now
the question is:
can you maybe
do knight E4?
Yes, he can  not double on E4 next to
C1 because of rook and then you would have a field on d5
then for the bishop also
yes
maybe
it's interesting I have to put a
little pressure on the clock first of all
like
F5 or D5 yes I could
beat them in each case no
probably  Wait a
minute, well, he has already moved, so
now I would have rook C2 too or
F6 F6 then go to where
G6 well rook C2 is also still possible
Queen C2 Queen E1 King we then you do
n't know what to play after that a
while  sometimes
he doesn't have a really good
field A3 A3 could be a move so
um if you now
ah wait a minute if I now play bishop F5
knight H4 tower C2 that's an
idea he always has tower E2 no
okay also has tower E4 h never
mind us  I have to play faster here
zack like checker checker E3 no damn G3
do it but take it
no
so
well position is pretty good now no but
I have 19 seconds oh
man
check yes well of course I'll lose
time here if he doesn't act completely stupid,
oh yeah  Now I've set it, yes,
I'm a duck too.
Terrible, terrible, my
God on time, yes, yes,
yes